WRESTLING INTER-RANCHO WRESTLING
CHAMPIONSHIP MATCH.
LET'S GET SWEATY AND WRESTLE!
COMING TO THE RING
NOW, YOU KNOW HIM,
YOU LOVE HIM--ESKIMOFO.
- RICKY, GET OUT.
- [yells]
- I WILL TEAR INTO MY OPPONENT
THE WAY THE MIGHTY KODIAK TEARS
INTO A SALMON!
- OKAY, THAT'S DISGUSTING.
THIS IS--THIS IS NOT--
- HE'S REALLY DOING THIS.
HE MUST BE GOOD AT WRESTLING.
I'LL SAY THAT RIGHT THERE.
DISGUSTING.
WAYMOND, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
OH, YOU PROBABLY LIKE THAT.
YOU ARE ASIAN.
- AND NOW JOINING US
IN THE EAST CORNER...
- COME UP.
COME UP.
- A NEW KID ON THE SCENE
BATTLING FOR THE BELT--
IT'S ADAM.
- WITH A SIMPLE NAME OF "ADAM."
HERE WE ARE. HERE WE ARE.
- SNAP INTO WRESTLING!
AND SNAP INTO...
- OKAY, OH!
- SLIM JIM!
- DUDE, I DON'T KNOW
IF WE CAN SAY THAT ON TV.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- OH, THAT WAS AWESOME.
- WE ARE RINGSIDE.
WE'RE READY TO GET STARTED.
OOH, IT'S A FURIOUS START
TO THE MATCH.
ESKIMOFO AND ADAM ARE DANCING.
- YEAH!
- WHOA!
- OH, MY GOD.
ARE YOU OKAY?
- WAS THAT GOOD?
- YEAH, YEAH, MAN.
YOU TOTALLY SOLD IT.
- OKAY.
- YOU TRICKED ME.
- REAL QUICK,
THOUGH--YOU'RE THE JABRONI.
- WHAT?
NO.
WE DIDN'T PLAN IT THAT WAY,
ALL RIGHT?
I WIN.
I GET THE GIRL.
- OKAY, I'M GONNA SUPLEX YOU.
- I'M GONNA SUPLEX YOU.
- ONE, TWO, SUPLEX.
- TIME OUT!
- OH!
- OH, WELL, IF IT
ISN'T MY BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTER,
BRATTY CATHY, EVERYONE.
- WHOO!
GET HIM, BABY.
- THE COMMISSIONER'S DAUGHTER
HAS SHOWED UP...
- EXCUSE ME.
- I SEE YOU'VE GOTTEN THE FUR
THAT DADDY
BOUGHT YOU WITH ALL HIS MONEY.
- OOH, CHA-CHING, CHA-CHING.
- all: OH!
- LOVE IT!
I LOVE IT!
- YOU READY TO WATCH
YOUR BOYFRIEND
AND MY FAVORITE WRESTLER,
ESKIMOFO, WIN THE MATCH?
- IS NOW THE TIME?
- NO, I ACTUALLY
WANT ADAM TO WIN!
WHOO!
- ONE,
TWO--
- OW!
OW!
- NICE.
- WHOO!
- I ALMOST PUT IT ON.
- TWO, THREE!
- YEAH!
- CHILD, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- THAT HURT.
- CHAMPION.
- NO!
- I'M THE CHAMPION.
- MY SWEET DAUGHTER'S ROOTING
FOR THAT GUY NOW?
NO!